hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's a new week in fortnight season X
it's week four already it's time for our
usual meetup going through all the map
changes and trying to figure out that
storyline that is kept so secret with
only subtle hints each week so do me a
favor slap Adam arrow in your supporter
creator and think about subscribing if
we hit 850 Kay I'll make some official
merch maybe even a but watch t-shirt
anyway you ready let's do this this week
our attention has firmly been around the
football field the soccer stadium
however you want to say it is fine with
me four days ago
yet another rift beacon appeared two
days later it was switched on and
yesterday it harnessed the power of the
zero point at lute Lake well today this
area is well well it's nothing at all
it's simply a pit I was unsure if this
was part of the visitors plan so I
checked the patch note from Epic Games
and found this the map has changed the
rift beacon at the Rec Center
malfunctioned causing an explosion that
left a giant crater and created glitched
consumables so right away we know that
the visitor may be some sort of science
buff in a certified brain box oh gee but
even he can mess things up to be honest
I reckon he was working on the rift but
was put off by that rec center and
couldn't resist scoring a goal or two
that lack of dedication caused the rift
beacon to mess up and destroy this great
landing spot which honestly if I still
made best landing spots in fortnight
videos I would have suggested this
landing spot but it's not so great
anymore so what's the drawer of this
area well the cool thing is the glitched
goodies consumables ranging from apples
and mushrooms to pop rocks those who
played back in season four will remember
the original crater and jumping around
in anti-gravity after eating one of
these but surprisingly that six not much
else to report on
[Music]
to quickly sort out a few things from
last week we looked at the winners World
Cups in solos and jewels found at lucky
landing and happy Hamlet some people
wanted to know where the heck the
creative copies and you'll find that bad
boy in the creative hub I really like
that touch GG for tonight devs also we
went over to Kevin's birthplace and
there's now a memorial there what I
didn't spot which thousands of you told
me in the comments that his resting
place is also in the game up at loot
Lake what a great tribute to our hero
from a simple lightning bolt to a
rolling cube of death to a floating cube
that exploded thanks for the memories
Kevin have you tried talking about Kevin
to people who don't play for at night
they look at you like you're insane but
for us who loved the game we know what
to do
come on guys press f to pay respects in
fact let's do one of those clickbait
things you have got ten seconds to press
F in the chat for Kevin the cube do it
or a spider will crawl up your buff
back over a dusty Depot deep depot de
pot yeah whatever you call it the
visitors lair is looking pretty fly
he's got widescreen TVs up he's got an
extra satellite dish on the roof to get
some adult channels if you know what I
mean and he's beginning to hit the
weights
he's really settling in the funny thing
is we haven't been able to confirm 100%
that this is his dusty even though we
think it's obvious it son confirmed
until now the dusty containers have been
added to creative and look at their name
dusty Depot visitors warehouse we no
longer need to speculate it's now
certain this is the visitors home so
let's keep an eye on it and maybe in a
few weeks we'll make an MTV style cribs
episodes there could be funny
week four of season X hasn't given as
many other changes not even the small
ones have you found any please let me
know I've checked risky reals no change
I've checked the golf Shack
no change the tree structures paradise
pounds nothing at all and of course the
one which hurts me the most cut watch
yeah yeah absolutely nothing at all sad
but true
hey fancy learning some Yorkshire that's
where I'm from in Yorkshire we don't say
nothing we say nowt try it
you two can sound like you have a severe
mental illness just like me yeah it's a
slow week I'm putting this video out
okay good watch and what about the rock
family we love so much not a single clue
anywhere we miss you rock the Dwayne
Johnson Sharon Stone kid rock pebbles
the rock piler maybe next week fam we
won't give up on you I've even gone so
far as to look on spawn island for
potential small changes this week and
have you noticed anything going on here
it's quite clever mixing the old island
with the new one the future one we have
a version of the original obstacle
course from the og Island we have the
container course introduced in season
two but the ancient buildings I think
they're from season six
am I wrong there and there's the
futuristic buildings we saw last season
in season nine but without a doubt the
greatest thing here is that the original
Tower Teddy and scarecrow are back again
from day one they watched over us and
now they have returned it's all about
nostalgia oh and the random building
with lots of televisions inside this is
so random I feel like it's a clue to
something but keep an eye on this at the
moment there are 10 televisions on the
ground could this link back to the TV
building over in West world we shall see
here's something interesting though epic
has said the update didn't go as planned
so maybe I'll be back in a few days with
a follow-up episode I get the feeling
the small changes they wanted to add in
didn't go as intended well I'm hoping
that anyway
so let's break this new information down
and put it into one of our cinematic
theories each week I ask you to comment
below or DM me on Twitter with your
season x theories and this week it's a
good one it was so good that I asked 100
of you guys to join me on stream to be
in a video and wind gifts by the way
we're doing it all over again this
Saturday I won't be covering it on
YouTube so if you'd like to join be sure
to follow me on Twitter for details the
last one was so much fun we just we just
have to do it again and I'm getting
sidetracked
I'm very sorry let's get back to this
for this week's story prediction we are
bringing back the enforcer unlocked for
completing challenges back in season 5
in the description we need to pay
attention to this check it balance and
order must be restored this led most of
us to believe that he was some sort of
time [ __ ] maybe part of an intergalactic
police force and judging by his back
blink a riot shield he's not afraid to
fight to preserve the order of time and
space so let's add him to the story
[Music]
we start this story by going back to the
future the meteor which crashed into the
island all those seasons ago we knew the
visitor was inside the capsule and we
watched him create a rocket to escape
our world but not long after he
disappeared the first time cop arrived
the enforcer the rupture in time and
space left by the visitor brought him
here but he was already too late the
visitor had left the enforcer continued
to chase him through the multiverse
until this moment arrived the visitor
did something unexpected he came back
again this time he had a different plan
to prevent the meteor from hitting the
island creating rift zones and changing
elements of the fortnight Island but
with every single rift he opened he gave
away his position the enforcers are
coming they must keep balance and
preserve time travels from breaking the
laws of our galaxy the visitors first
attempt to bend time and space took us
back to the Old West
the second brought tusks the undead
caught in time and now in his third
attempt things are even worse
the visitor has completely messed up
he's failed he reduced the stadium and
surrounding area to ash breaking the
time line so much that items were
jumping between dimensions he should
have been working but he just unlocked
the bottle flip him out but now the
enforcer knows his location they are
waiting for the right time to strike
growing in numbers the visitor knows
this and he builds mechs to aid his
cause but the war will begin soon who
will win and who is the good guy in this
situation find out next week on
Playstation grenade
ok so forgive my overacting but what do
you think to that theory it's pretty
good isn't it but who really would be
the good guy in that scenario the time
cops are the visitor and what will they
do with the visitor once he's caught
intergalactic courtroom drama or maybe
they'll simply beat him to death with
pickaxes let me know your theories I'm
really into this oh and if you want to
be in the next story cinematic we are
making it this Saturday so follow me on
Twitter
I'm Adam grenade I'm organizing yet
another super secret meter
so there we have it thanks to all the
legends that have helped me in this
week's story hopefully you can find your
names in here somewhere and of course we
need the legends roll call all these
badasses used my code are tomorrow in
the FATA night shop and bought something
and then sent me a DM for a shout-out I
thank you all so much all your support
means more giveaways in our streams you
really our legends to me anyway I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure sorry there wasn't much to go
through this week hopefully things will
change and I'll see you next time thanks
again see you soon hey did you make it
all the way to the end of the video you
are my hero
here's a thing just for you guys who got
to the end the first person to guess
where the next rift beacon will appear
in fortnight will be gifted something
from me I'll even add you to my friends
list how does that sound I really
appreciate that you stay more than two
minutes it means a lot to me I'll try
and find different ways to gift things
at the end of videos in future thanks
again I'll catch you soon
[Music]